simplify the expression using rational
exponents so we have the cube root of
all of this stuff over here which would
be the same thing or which is the same
thing by definition as all of this stuff
64 a to the sixth B to the 3rd C to the
9th raised to the 1/3 power these are
equivalent by definition and if we take
the product of a bunch of things and
raise them to an exponent that's the
same thing as raising each of these
things that we're taking the product off
to the exponent first and then
multiplying so this is going to be equal
to 64 to the 1/3 power times a to the
6th to the 1/3 power times B to the 3rd
to the 1/3 power times C to the 9th to
the 1/3 power and we've seen this in
several examples already well first
let's try to simplify this 64 to the 1/3
you might recognize that already but we
can factor 64 as well I won't do a pure
prime factorization because you'll see
it's 4 to the 3rd power actually you can
verify that for yourself or I encourage
you if you if that's not obvious to see
that this is 4 to the 3rd power 64
multiply it out for yourself or if
you're like how did you know that do the
prime factorization and what you're
gonna do is if you well let me just show
if you do the prime factorization gonna
have 2 times 32 32 is 2 times 16 16 is 2
times 8 8 is 2 times 4 and the 4 is 2
times 2 so you can have 2 multiplied by
itself three times or you can have it 2
multiplied by itself three times and
that happens twice or you could have 4
times 4 times 4 so if you if you didn't
if it immediately didn't jump in your
head that 64 is 4 to the third power
you can literally do a brute force prime
factorization here and see that you have
six you can factor this into 2 to the
sixth power or the same thing as for the
third power so I'll let out I'll let you
think about that a little bit but this
right here simplifies if 64 is 4 to the
third power and you raise that to the
1/3 power that is the same thing
actually let me write it that way that
could make it more interesting so this
right here this is 4 to the third power
so if I I have 4 to the third power and
then that raised to the 1
third power so if I want to rewrite that
term right over here that's going to be
four to the three thirds power
I'm literally multiplying 3 times 1/3 4
to the third and then that to the
one-third then over here I have a to the
sixth and then that to the 1/3 power
that is going to be a to the 6 times 1/3
power or a to the 6 thirds power then I
have B to the third and then that raised
to the 1/3 so that's going to be we
literally can multiply exponents here so
we have B to the 3 over 3 power and then
finally we have C to the 9th and then
that raced and then that raised to the
1/3 power so that is C to the 9 over 3
power and if you simplify it in this
first term here 4 to the 3rd 3 thirds
that's just 4 to the first power so
that's just 4 we have a to the 6 third
six thirds is just 2 so that just
becomes a squared B to the 3/3 power
that's just B to the first or B and then
finally C to the 9/3 that's just C to
the third power so we write C to the
third here and we are done